world leaders are denouncing russia's
invasion with the head of the european
union calling it barbaric the front
pages of newspapers in this country and
overseas say it all on the first day of
what threatens to be europe's largest
land war in more than 75 years mts tayab
is in london watching the reaction mtas
good morning
adriana everyone good morning while the
world is largely reacting with fury the
u.s japan australia and canada all
issuing statements condemning the attack
with the british prime minister boris
johnson saying the world cannot look
away and is promising to retaliate with
an unprecedented level of sanctions
russia's strike on ukraine has also
triggered a wave of anger across the
continent with europe's leaders
demanding russia stop its invasion
once again in the center of europe
innocent women men and children are
dying
of fear for their lives
we condemn this
barbaric attack
and the cynical arguments to justify it
now the un secretary general is warning
the war could trigger a humanitarian
catastrophe saying it would quote cause
a level of suffering not seen in europe
since the balkan crisis but one nation
china is taking a different track with a
chinese foreign ministry spokeswoman
refusing this morning to describe
russia's military assault as an invasion
following russia's attract on ukraine
which is a flagrant violation of
international law vladimir putin now
faces a wall of solidarity from the west
and an incoming wave of economic pain
nate
mts in london thank you
just keep thinking about the people in
ukraine who woke up to the sound of
explosions their windows rattling babies
crying dogs barking it's something we've
never experienced in this country and
it's absolutely terrifying and you know
they've been targeting military
facilities that we saw in charlie
daggett's piece that buildings are being
targeted actual residences are not
targeted but being affected by all this
and now you have lines at gas stations
lines at atms lines on the highway and
we're hearing from the world leaders and
they are speaking out against what's
going on